[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
that's just too easy
that's way too easy Hollis Jeff now
watches little Russell I mean that that
defense is he was a important basket
this state even though the lead is still
really solid
there's Russell provides his first
basket of this half you know again a
buddy starts making these outside shots
wow what a terrible pass you don't see
that very often from Harry he's a very
good pass no he's very skilled pass it
but that was a again trying to be more
creative than necessary a clock at five
baseline jumper and Buddy hield how'd it
go off his shoulder Russell three on the
way and that makes it a 13-point in 107
94 it's getting quiet here in Sacramento
TenPoint game
12 to 104
Russell how quick was that from a great
screen nearby Dudley aurelio freed up
Paula D'Angelo Russell leads all scorers
with 32 points and make that 34 points
114 the 108 move without the ball and
spread the floor good things happen
three-pointer but boy how about the show
we're seeing here see why he was the
second pick in the draft
Duncan Fisher do is career highs 40
turnover here's Russell you can exhale
now Jerry
bucks goes pretty steal rustlers open
[Applause]
you know you're almost glad you didn't
score a three-pointer you know what it
means here that's how hotties good
the official said no we got it on the
way up another look another look at
D'Angelo